This is why i never had kids
that might be one of the coolest things that's
ever happened to me but don't ever do that
peter you're struggling and everything you
want while the world tries to make you choose.
Welcome back everyone this will be my full
spider-man no way home trailer breakdown
there's a couple new alternate versions of the
trailer with some new scenes that also work into
this as well like the new clip at the beginning
of this with spider-man versus doctor strange
there's also a lot of questions that you've
asked me about alternate versions of green goblin
and just weird scenes in general that didn't
totally make sense so i'll explain everything
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'm doing a
giveaway for imax tickets for the movie all you
have to do to enter is just be a subscriber and
leave your favorite easter egg from the trailer
on the video i'm sure you've all watched the
trailer a billion times but since sony dropped
the trailer there's been a couple alternate
versions of the trailer that have dropped on
international accounts with different footage
the first one having that alternate footage
of doctor strange just reeling spider-man in
after he first tries to steal away with the
box and get away so he can save the sinister
six villains and they don't have to go back to
their universes and die their whole conflict in
that part of the movie is basically spider-man
not wanting to send them back to their deaths
last night sony did a big event for the movie and
they did a big trailer premiere inside an actual
movie theater tom holland showed up and started
talking about other parts of the movie as well too
one of the things he said about his version of
peter parker during the movie makes a little
more sense when you consider why spider-man is
fighting doctor strange for this mystery box
to try and save the sinister six spider-man's
biggest superpower is peter parker and that's
because of his humility that's what sets him
apart from the rest is that he's always able
he's unable to not do the right thing and for me
as an actor bringing that to life has been so fun
because it's sometimes incredibly frustrating
sometimes i i read these scripts where i perform
these scenes and i just want peter parker to
be selfish just one time because he always he
always puts everybody else first and therefore he
kind of he kind of shits on himself so what he's
basically saying is that he's going to do the
right thing no matter what even if it puts them
at odds with doctor strange which is how they
come to this impasse at this part of the film
but it's a bit of a misdirect it's not like doctor
strange is going to be a villain to spider-man
inside the spider-man movie it's just about him
trying to find the best way to fix this problem
whereas doctor strange doesn't care so much he
doesn't have a problem making that moral choice
like well they were supposed to die originally
so we're just fixing things so that they happen
the way that they were supposed to happen even if
it's a very grim ending for their characters they
also released another alternate scene of doctor
strange we started getting some visitors based
on the context it sounds like that's happening
right after spider-man messes up their spell and
doctor strange senses immediately that they're
going to quote unquote have some visitors and
that's a reference to the sinister six characters
coming from the tobey maguire spider-man movies in
the andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies and
then he sets them on their very scooby-doo tasks
literally calling them the scooby gang i also
tried to work in the brazil edit of the trailer
to the beginning of this video too if you didn't
see that version of the trailer that everyone was
talking about because it seems like the lizard
is getting punched by nothing in the middle of
this fight like clearly it seems like there's
another version of spider-man during this fight
if not two other versions for toby maguire and
andrew garfield spider-man he moves right there
coincidence i think not like did tom holland's mcu
spider-man just develop air powers how is he doing
this to the lizard if there's not another version
of spider-man just hidden in this frame somewhere
the funny thing too is that it's only this one
alternate brazil version of the trailer on their
twitter account if you go to their youtube account
it's playing the exact same version of the trailer
that's on all the other main accounts jamie foxx
also just posted this on his instagram and it said
chasing spiders as in multiple spiders so i'm sure
he's about to get a phone call from kevin feige
that a lot of you also asked about this weird
scene here when spider-man is ducking through
all the scaffolding and the statue of liberty
fight some people think that this is an alternate
version of spider-man like either tobey maguire
andrew garfield and it's just been photoshopped
to look like tom hall and spider-man like they
just re-skinned him a little bit to be tom hall
and spider-man but really it's another version
of spider-man and it's all because of the eyes
this is what the eyes the irises look like on the
advanced suit they're the same eyes that he's had
on all of his other spider-man costumes in the
mcu but in this scene the eyes look completely
different so people just think that they try
to cover up another version of spider-man by
re-skinning him but they forgot to cover up the
face you can argue in the comments whether or
not you think this is actually a thing or if you
think this is still just tom hall and spider-man
some of you have also asked about the andrew
garfield easter egg during the gwen stacy scene
like yes the scene itself is an andrew garfield
amazing spider-man 2 easter egg for the gwen
stacy death scene the dialogue in the trailer
where tom holland says i can't save everyone
when he reaches for her you notice that his glove
looks blue and red a lot of people were wondering
if that's andrew garfield's glove because his
costume in the amazing spider-man movies had
red and blue gloves but here's the thing during
this big statue of liberty fight he's wearing
the integrated suit which is like a new upgraded
version of the iron spider suit that suit has blue
and red gloves kind of like the amazing spider-man
version of the suit so when he's reaching for her
with his hand here this is still tom holland's
mcu spider-man the theory was is that if there
was gonna be some big twist here maybe it winds up
being andrew garfield spider-man who does save her
sort of redeeming himself for not being able to
save gwen stacy during the amazing spider-man 2.
but one of the other biggest questions i saw in
my trailer reaction video yesterday was about this
scene of the green goblin a lot of you thought
that this was like a second version of the green
goblin like is there two versions of green goblin
in the movie so just to be clear there's only one
version of green goblin in the film it's willem
dafoe's green goblin from the first tobey maguire
spider-man movie you can see pretty clearly that
they just tuned his costume up a little bit with
the modern special effects but it's the same basic
costume that he wore in that first movie but later
in this scene at night when he's flying towards
the frame on his glider he just isn't wearing his
helmet he's wearing goggles instead and they're
kind of like the goggles that the harry osborne
green goblin wore in spider-man 3. so that's why
a lot of people were confused because it's kind of
blurry it's at night you can't clearly see that
it's willem dafoe but it is meant to be willem
dafoe's green goblin he just wearing goggles and
not wearing the mask they're not bringing james
franco's green goblin back or anything like that
and it's not meant to be an easter egg for ned
leeds hobgoblin because in the comics ned lee's
became hobgoblin so a lot of people have been
wondering through this trilogy if we're going to
see some easter eggs for that there is a really
questionable ned lead scene in this big action
sequence that i'll talk about later in the video
green goblin's speech to spider-man in the trailer
about the world trying to force him to choose who
he's supposed to be is meant to be a big callback
to his speech in the first toby maguire spider-man
movie when he gave similar advice to toby
mcguire's spider-man saying we are who we
choose to be you're struggling to have everything
you want while the world tries to make you choose
the truth of that is that tom holland toby mcguire
spider-man even andrew garfield spider-man all get
to be the ones to decide their own fate who they
get to be they don't have to let the world choose
that for them the other ned leeds scene that i
was referring to was during the big gwen stacy
scene when they're making the big reference to
the amazing spider-man 2 and her death mj falls
off the statue of liberty because you can see it
in the background they're on the scaffolding here
ned lee's is still wearing his letterman jacket
from midtown high and he's up there with her
reaching for her as she falls so a lot of people
are just wondering now is ned leeds going to be
the one that dies during the film like will there
be a big death amongst his friends it's always
possible i don't think that they're going to kill
mj like i said big andrew garfield theory there
like either tom hall and spider-man will wind up
saving her or andrew garfield spider-man will wind
up saving her so she's safe she's wearing some
plot armor ned leeds however does not get the same
kind of plot armor but that doesn't mean they're
going to kill him off or turn him into hobgoblin
like i would be blown away super surprised if we
saw future ned lee's hop goblin i just don't think
that that's going to happen but talking about the
other footage so when spider-man and mj are at the
top of the bridge here it seems like they're on
the queensboro bridge and he's trying to take her
home during this larger fight where he's running
from the new york city police department like
they're web slinging through the city past all
these billboards with jay jonah jameson yelling
about spider-man then while they're trying to
escape the police he takes her into the subway
tunnels and they almost get hit by the subway
train like can you duck the subway train yes
but can you also do it while you're carrying
mj with you yes it is a big reference to tobey
maguire in the subway fight scene with doctor
octopus during spider-man 2 but there were also
a couple of similar scenes during the andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man movies it's just
that subway cars are such a big part of the new
york city landscape they always feel compelled to
have some sort of action scene involving a train
in all spider-man movies but the whole idea is
that eventually he does make it back home but then
the police finally start showing up to everyone's
houses in queens so he finally gets hauled in for
questioning about all mysterio's drones the video
still seems like it's pretty early in the movie
and then that's when he gets the idea to go to
doctor strange for the spell i've already talked
about the easter eggs for the spell itself it is
a big mephisto one more day comic book storyline
easter egg but then because of this new trailer
footage we know that spider-man legit messes
up the spell like while it's happening maybe
we can make it so that a couple people remember
everything and doctor strange is trying to tell
him what this is happening stop messing with us
that's not how it works everyone has to forget
about you pretty much anyone who's had any kind
of experience with him while he's been spider-man
and because he messes with it that's what causes
the other sinister six films to start showing up
but the new scene of doctor strange after this
reacting to everything getting messed up makes it
sound like things from every universe are going to
start crossing over eventually like it will start
with the sinister six villains but then at the end
of the trailer with that tag scene where you see
like the purple tears in the sky like the fabric
of reality is just breaking down around them and
he says i can't stop it they're coming because
captain america shield is not on the statue
of liberty here there's just all this rubble
around it it seems like it's happening after
their big final boss fight with the sinister six
characters and this is at the very end of the film
and it seems like what they're implying is that
it just starts with the sinister six characters
coming from alternate universes but then really
really terrible things like dormammu level
villains start to make their way into the mcu and
that's sort of the wtf cliffhanger teaser that
leads into doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
because that's going to be the next marvel movie
right after spider-man no way home it would not be
a spider-man movie if he won did not cause all the
problems that he winds up having to solve because
he messes the spell up but also too in trying
to fix everything he causes larger problems that
lead to even bigger consequences in future marvel
movies but the marvel movies have been doing
that for a long time now like the avengers fix
one problem but in doing so cause an even bigger
problem like at the end of the first avengers
movie they defeat loki the shitauri army and that
leads to thanos saying fine i'll do it myself and
he comes to earth himself and just wrecks them all
there's already so many things going on in this
movie i'm not expecting a ton of scarlet witch
doctor strange two stuff but i do think that we
will see a venom let there be carnage post credit
scene just to address what happened in the venom
let there be carnage post-credits scene like oh
you thought that you dealt with all the problems
that had bled into this universe nope there's
one more one more problem to fix in a future
film i've already talked about the doctor octopus
green goblin bridge fight early in the film when
he's fighting both of them at the same time white
doctor octopus is all confused seeing that he's
not the tobey maguire spider-man like wait a
minute you're not the spider-man that i know
here's the thing with doctor octopus though him
taking the iron spider nanites is a cool callback
to the first iron man film originally kevin feige
wanted to make iron man the person who created
doctor octopus's arms and they were going to use
that as a sort of retcon kind of easter egg in
the first iron man film because that first iron
man movie came out right after spider-man 3. so
toby maguire was still spider-man and he wanted
to connect the brand new mcu as it was developing
to the tobey maguire spider-man movies sony
said no dice because they were in the process of
rebooting things to the amazing spider-man andrew
garfield franchise but originally what probably
would have happened in that first iron man film
is they would have just had a reference or an
easter egg in the background to doctor octopus
like his arms are stark tech and that would have
been it like you wouldn't have seen alfred molina
starring in iron man 1 because he would have been
dead at that point in the timeline but at some
point he's able to capture him and they get him
in this prison cell in the basement of the sanctum
you notice though the way they're dressed and they
have ned lee's laptop there so they've already
gone into full scooby mode so it's after doctor
strange gives them the scooby doo business zoom
in enhance on his laptop there he has the this
is fine meme too like everything's on fire but
this is fine which is just commentary on the plot
of the movie like things are completely on fire
around them all of reality is starting to crumble
and universes are starting to bleed over into each
other but this is totally fine everything is fine
there's a couple scenes later in the trailer that
make it seem though like doctor octopus winds up
helping spider-man and doctor strange like if he
has a similar arc that continues on from the end
of spider-man 2 because at the end of that movie
he becomes good again like he gains control of
his mind from his arms and helps save the city
by pulling his reactor down into the east river
so one it seems like he's giving some counsel to
spider-man here explaining why the other sinister
six villains will die if they go home that's
why he says you're going to be chasing ghosts
but also you notice later in the trailer it
seems like doctor octopus is getting blasted
by electro through this building here and doctor
octopus does not show up anywhere in this statue
of liberty fight scene so what happens to him why
isn't he here does he die earlier in the movie or
does something happen to him does he try to help
spider-man and the other sinister six villains try
to take him out you can post all your theories
in the comments below but it just sounds like
they're giving him a similar arc as he had during
spider-man 2 like he'll be fighting spider-man for
part of the movie and helping him for the other
part of the film and speaking of sinister six
films i know i talked about the phantom andrew
garfield amazing spider-man scene here with the
lizard but during one of these scenes here you
notice a big comic book easter egg for electro so
he actually develops this electric halo around his
head that looks like the star from his costume in
the comics his actual physical costume too kind of
resembles the spider-man ps4 electro costume it's
just like a harness that that version wore but
this is all just a really cool way to make him
a little bit more comic book accurate give him
that weird looking star shape around his head
the other big easter egg that a lot of you
noticed in the trailer was the scene of
aunt may she's running but she's holding this
green canister that seems very similar to the
green oscorp canisters of the goblin serum
from the tobey maguire spider-man movies
there's not a lot of other context for what's
happening during this scene here it just seems
like this is green goblin related and for those
of you that are asking about the ending of the
eternals movie with the giant stone celestial
that's now just jutting out from the indian
ocean like a giant chunk of the earth is now
covered in stone celestial i'm not expecting
them to reference that a ton during this movie
but i do believe that spider-man no way home is
supposed to take place right after the end of
the eternals movie there's a couple other minor
easter eggs that i talked about during my trailer
reaction video yesterday so i'll link that at the
end of this just so i don't have to repeat myself
in this video but if you did spot any other easter
eggs from the trailer that i didn't talk about in
the video just write them below in the comments
there's a couple more spider-man videos that i'm
working on so i'll post those in the next couple
of days my full hawkeye episodes we'll start
posting next week too that's right hawkeye
starts next week so make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss those episodes
congratulations juan andres molina you're the
giveaway winner from my last big spider-man
video please email me on the about page of
my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here to re-watch the spider-man
no way home trailer a billion more times
and click here for my brand new moon
night trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and
i'll see you guys in the next one!